determinan el número de soluciones de la
ecuación cuadrática x cuadrada más 14 x
49 igual a 0 y hay un montón de formas
en que podríamos resolver esto por
ejemplo podríamos factorizar don y
simplemente descubrir los valores de x
que las satisfagan y después solo
contarlos ese sería nuestro número de
soluciones otra forma sería simplemente
aplicar la fórmula cuadrática pero lo
que quiero hacer en este momento es
explorar la fórmula cuadrática y pensar
en cómo podemos determinar el número de
soluciones sin siquiera tal vez
necesariamente hallar las de una forma
explícita bueno la fórmula cuadrática
nos dice que si tenemos una ecuación de
la forma a x cuadrada más bx más c igual
a cero entonces las soluciones van a ser
de la forma o las soluciones si existen
son de la forma x es igual a menos b
más menos y justo aquí es la razón del
por qué puede haber dos soluciones pues
es que aquí tenemos un más menos si b
cuadrada menos 40 es un número positivo
y mejor espera espera espera mejor deja
terminar la fórmula la raíz cuadrada de
b cuadrada menos 4 hacen todo esto entre
2 am y bueno déjame pensar un poco más
en esto a ver si b cuadrada menos 4
hacer esto es mayor que 0
entonces qué pasa bueno si esto pasa
adentro de la raíz tenemos un número
positivo por lo cual podemos sacar la
raíz cuadrada y después cuando lo
sumamos con menos 20 vamos a obtener un
valor para el numerador y cuando tú lo
reste es al menos b vamos a obtener otro
valor distinto en el numerador así que
cuando pasa esto vamos a obtener dos
soluciones dos soluciones cuando b
cuadrada menos 4 hace es mayor que cero
vamos a obtener
soluciones ahora que pasan cuando ve
cuadrada menos 4 cm es igual a 0
bueno si la expresión dentro de la raíz
es igual a cero entonces tendremos que
sacar la raíz cuadrada de 0 la cual es 0
la raíz cuadrada de 0 es cero por lo
tanto nos quedaría menos b más o menos 0
y no importa lo que le sume solo le
reste 0 siempre vas a obtener el mismo
valor así que en esta situación la
solución de la ecuación va a ser menos b
entre 2 a esta vez no vamos a tener más
o menos pues no va a ser relevante por
lo tanto vamos a tener una única
solución menos b / 2a
es decir que tenemos b cuadrada menos 4
cm igual a cero entonces vamos a tener
sólo una solución y bueno después qué va
a pasar siempre cuadrada menos 4 cm es
menor que cero bueno pues si b cuadrada
menos 4 sep es menor que cero entonces
es un número negativo el cual vamos a
tener dentro de la raíz cuadrada y
entonces tenemos que tomar la raíz
cuadrada de un número
y nosotros sabemos porque nosotros
trabajamos con los números reales que no
podemos tomar esta raíz cuadrada pues no
es un número real así que nuestra
situación no existen soluciones o mejor
dicho no existen soluciones reales y
bueno cuando digo reales me refiero
literalmente a números reales no a
soluciones reales aquí lo voy a poner no
hay solución real no hay soluciones
reales así que una vez dicho esto
pensemos en el contexto de esta ecuación
que tenemos aquí que por cierto en el
dado caso de que tú seas muy curioso y
te preguntas si esta expresión be
cuadrada menos 4 sep tiene un nombre
especial pues sí lo tiene se llama
discriminante el discriminante
discriminante el cual es esta parte de
la fórmula cuadrática el que determina
el número de soluciones que vamos a
tener así que si queremos determinar el
número de soluciones que vamos a tener
en esta ecuación aquí entonces no
necesariamente tenemos que resolver toda
la fórmula cuadrática
aunque tal vez no sea mucho trabajo pero
podemos determinar el número de
soluciones evaluando la expresión de
cuadrada menos 4 a 0 y bueno ahora sí
llegó a la hora de pensar en este caso
particular
vamos a buscar quienes ven quienes han y
quién es este de aquí este es el que
está al lado de la equis este otro que
está al lado de la equis cuadrada es am
mientras que éste me termino libre ese y
ahora sí
si nosotros sustituimos buscando b
cuadrada menos 4 hacen entonces me va a
quedar 14 elevado al cuadrado menos
cuatro por amd pero a vale uno por ser
pero se vale 49 entonces por 49 y
cuantos esto pues vamos a hacerlo cuánto
es 14 por 14 lo voy a hacer por aquí y
14 por 14 y me quedan 4 x 4 16 y
llevamos 14 por 14 y 15 después ponemos
un cero aquí y 14 por una es qatar
ahora si sumamos me quedan 69 1 196 14 x
14 196 y bueno por otra parte tengo 4
por 49 así que vamos a hacerlo también
por aquí 4 por 49 9 por 4 36 y llevamos
3 4 por 4 16 y 3 19 196 también y cuando
yo me tomo 196 mil 296 esto me da 0
entonces estamos en el caso en el que el
discriminante es igual a cero o dicho de
otra manera estamos en este caso de aquí
en el caso en el que b cuadrada menos 4
ac es igual a 0 y por lo tanto estoy
diciendo que solamente tengo una
solución e inclusive si quieres podemos
encontrar la única solución esta parte
de aquí va a ser la raíz cuadrada de 0 y
por lo tanto esto desaparece así que las
soluciones de esta ecuación van a ser
menos b entre 2 am y menos b podemos
sustituir lo es menos 14 entre 2 samb es
decir 2 por 1
lo cual es 2
y esto es igual a menos 7 esta es la
única solución de esta ecuación pero si
solo quisiera saber cuántas soluciones
tienen sólo tendrías que ver que el
discriminante 0 y por lo tanto solo vas
a tener una solución y bueno también hay
otras maneras podrías factorizar lo cual
también es sencillo pues esto que está
aquí es lo mismo que x + 7 x x + 7 y con
esto obtendrías el mismo resultado